it's official everybody knows i don't
moisturize okay welcome back um this
hour we are talking about all things
animal okay who in this audience has a
pet will you raise your hand yep double
hands there double hands uh-huh uh-huh
oh
i worry for the people that don't have
pets
why do i feel that way okay uh you had
an enthusiastic two hands up hi drew hi
everyone hi
i have the world's greatest dog i'm
sorry to everyone else that has
wonderful dogs but i have a sweet little
he just turned three years old his name
is scuttle he's a toy poodle and he is
the sweetest dog in the world i dressed
all pride in june i had him in a rainbow
costume all summer long everywhere we
went people acted like they had never
seen a dog before
he's the cutest sweetest dog and i feel
so lucky and so blessed
every day i stare at this dog and i'm
like how are you real how are you this
cute how do i get to live with you and
cuddle with you and snuggle with you
every day oh my gosh
see for everybody who didn't raise your
hand that's i'm like this is possible
this is there right for the taking i
mean did you ever think about if a pet
could affect your health
because right now we're going to discuss
some of the health benefits that humans
do get from animals in the segment
called good in five animal addition now
first um there's something to know
according to the waltham pet care
science institute owning a pet can help
lower your blood pressure your heart
rate and reduce stress but if you don't
have a pet listen maybe you don't have
the time or the space or economically it
doesn't make sense for you i totally get
that but we actually have you covered
because a study by the university of
leeds in the uk examined the effects of
watching images and videos of cute
animals for 30 minutes um and the
results in participants were a drop in
blood pressure
over 6 reduction in heart rates and 35
reduction in anxiety levels so if you're
feeling stressed out today here's
someone to follow it's henry the
colorado dog and that is an instagram
account
dedicated to this friendship right
do you guys hear that reaction i mean
that's insane
oh no
i mean this is baloo who's the cat
and they are best friends and they sleep
together
and um
i just love this account and i love
their friendship and i every time i look
at these pictures i just
it makes me feel good about life and
finally something to do
all right
i have never done this before um one
stress reducing trend that has a
resurgence all around the country is
none other than goat yoga and here to
tell us all about this trend and the
benefits are
sharon boostingly and kelly morrissey
the owner and instructor of new york
goat yoga hi guys hi drew
no you guys are the only ones in new
york is this
we were the first first to bring goat
yoga to new york pioneers definitely
yeah
exactly all right now you have a very
fast-paced life sharon and i was
wondering
what possessed you to make the change
so in 2005 we were a family of six new
york city family from queens live in the
rat race
and we were looking for an escape so we
found 125 acre farm in upstate new york
and i learned to connect with nature to
slow my pace down
and we started new york's first
luxury farm event venue it's a
destination venue
and then right after that we decided
that we were going to incorporate a lot
of fun into it and we decided to start
goat yoga um okay and kelly what are the
benefits of incorporating goats into
your yoga because i'm actually
like i think i've been doing yoga for 30
years i've never done it with a goat
it is a new experience for everyone
incorporating a goat in your practice is
going to help you relax a little bit
more you can really kind of check out
from the world setting aside ego setting
aside worries and burdens they just kind
of like take it all away from you you
know just that nurturing and cuddling
it's great stuff oh hi who are you how
are you you know what's really fun about
goat yoga is that it really connects
people
they're your biggest fans just letting
you know
very honored
it really connects people to each other
uh-huh
and it's an instant icebreaker so when
you're in the yoga class before the
goats walk in you know everybody's you
know nobody knows each other right but
as soon as these goats come prancing
through the door it's just everybody
just melts and everybody has such a
great time together which is a really
nice um part of it kelly you're going to
show me some yoga poses and uh sharon
you're going to wrangle the goats is
that correct
all right what's first
first we're going to do some child's
pose so let's sink back onto our heels
you can bring your forearms down to the
mat maybe even rest your head on the mat
it feels wonderful when they walk on
your back
nice deep massage
oh hi
[Laughter]
[Music]
does it feel good
they're they're very they're touches
haven't we all been faced down with uh
you know a couple of goats running all
over us um
okay which pose is next oh hi
[Laughter]
this is table pose with a goat on your
table
[Laughter]
that's what i'm here for
[Laughter]
excellent
good job awesome
you know what's surprising is how not
painful that oh hi
how not painful this is it's like really
really comfortable
very
very soft touches
um
i mean i
i i i'm enjoying the feeling of their
hooves
all right
let's just come down to our tummies
just laying down maybe we'll find
ourselves in
superman pose today
nice deep inhale
with the exhale have you ever seen oh my
god
[Applause]
it's a good thing
that i was
[Applause]
rosie loves you i was about to have a
new form of goat yoga
the old oh my god
[Laughter]
well i think this has been a complete
success
um
all right sharon and kelly thank you so
much for coming here and sharing your
adorable goats with us and for more
information on new york goat yoga and
other distressing tips and places to go
come to our website at
thedrewbearmoreshow.com and we'll get
you there
[Music]